[Music]
the first ride is the straight wall ride
the second act is our go-kart so it's
four wheels this time per day it's right
in one of these lovely ladies and when
you do hands off
stand it up hands off sitting on the
sides standing on the side as a whole
array of acts it's an experience you
can't prepare anything in the world too
I'm Kerry Cameron and I'm wall of death
Rider and I ride for Luke Fox's original
wall of death I started writing the wall
of death by pure accident I used to work
with horses and unfortunately where I
was working in the place shut down
so naturally we went to the Jobcentre
and I just typed in horse rider into the
third engine and we'll a diff rider came
up and I went down to the yard and they
had the wall built up I knew there and
then that was it
you do you're very dizzy on your first
burns ride because you've got buildings
down there up to the dizziness it has to
go at least first email out to stay on
with otherwise gravity will just whip
you straight off it's a mixture free
thing so balance speed and I'll see a
bit of stamina just lifting your arm up
it's a way of good bias the audience is
quite a feat it's a good feeling being a
female rider in this masculine vironment
it gives me a great buzz because a lot
of people when they see you walk into
the wall they just think they're a bit
of flash you know but as soon as they
see you get on the bike you can hear
like murmur saying oh there's a girl
almost
I see all that faces like up and then
after the show all the girls they were
like wow you've got bigger balls and
most of the men but but it's it's great
to know that they look new you thinking
bully if you could do it then so can I
[Music]
imagine you're driving through the hot
Moroccan desert your car breaks down and
the nearest village is 20 miles away
would you panic would you give up would
you convert your car into a motorbike in
a lengthy process that might get you
killed
eats a meal the Ray the mechanical
magician who did just that close to a
small town in France there is a man that
loves cars rule specifically the French
Citroen 2cv like those
[Music]
and he's got this funny-looking
motorbike with an extraordinary story
behind it I mean of rocket her husband
just visit my office and English
Canadians a new voice for any problem so
suppose a when you would antivirus
epithelium is only minute my IT
community Imam Mahdi the Abu sistema de
Tony attenti krishna pathi donkey
simulate our jobs oftentimes if a
document known as European did we had
dementia see obviously like any stranded
desert traveler emile decided to turn
the still working parts of that car into
this motorbike first he removed the cars
frame said kiss Mousavi penuche canvas
available in city mamizou judo mira
family put then he shortened it to make
a better chassis fix the axles and put
the wheels on the bike simple right no
oh yeah he also added suspension and
well an engine and ignition and a
comfortable seat after 12 days and 11
nights in the desert he was ready to go
back to civilization Roger Philipp
massage will do damage he looked at the
tape machine she came to Mahatma is your
SuperSpeed on this day on the ice on
dirt and time finally to his delight he
came upon the police who greeted him
with hefty fine caffeine sanctions icon
to DRS key figures a second to all the
physical CD like movie unit to be fulfil
my captive individual back in France the
motorcycle ended up alongside Emile's
other Centurion creations like this boat
this rugby ball a table saw and even
glasses made out of rubber from the seat
the sky really was citrus
makes you wonder what's next
[Music]
first of all we're girly girls we like
to be cute but we still get dirty
every time we come out our shoes our
outfits I always mention I make of this
done is it hard to write in heels no
because if you can walk in them you can
probably ride in them
we're not the typical biker chicks when
the curves come on the set is complete
chaos
my name is true and I'm one of the
founders of caramel curves motorcycle
club here in New Orleans my name is Coco
and I'm one of the founders and the
president of caramel curves motorcycle
club we are a motorcycle club like no
others we come out club ready every time
we hit the streets when we first started
off I just rolled by myself and then
Coco she just rolled by herself
we kind of got together and was like
let's start something together cuz the
guys always have their bike clubs but
what's more sexy than riding with a
bunch of girls nothing nothing that uh
the name caramel curves was made up by
luck we came up with caramel because of
the complexion of our skin and then we
came up with curves but some reason but
when we take curves on a motorbike
better than a mane and we some curvy
girls we are mothers we are daughters we
are everything that every other average
woman is in a world
I'm really really passionate about
female empowerment women knowing that
they can do whatever they want to do
riding bikes used to be a guy thing
we're still being discriminated against
across the board being a caramel curve
we have demanded our respect I just
encourage any woman that wants to ride a
bike that thinks that she can't do it
girl you can do that [ __ ] you know go
ahead the coolest thing about being a
caramel curved biker chick is the
response and the love that we get from
from kids up to women when the little
kids look up to us it's that thing that
makes her feel like you know what if she
can do it I can do it you that's what
makes you feel like yeah you know what
let's keep going on being a caramel car
I truly feel like is my legacy I'm a
rock cross country I'm gonna go live and
I'm gonna do it in heels
we're a big group of strong women that
takes risks riding motorcycles all the
time in the city which takes a set of
steel ovaries in my opinion but we want
to help babies he says no to babies
the club delivers process and
pasteurized donor breast milk to mothers
and babies in need both to Nick use in
hospitals and to private homes we focus
our service on the women's health issues
so this is complete fit for what we try
to do as a club the call for milk can
come at any time you can be anywhere we
pull up to the dock at the New York milk
Bank Julie brings out the milk that's
been prepackaged in freezer bags and
boxes we strap it down to the
motorcycles zip away when we opened up
the milk bank
I was actually stuck in traffic with my
husband and saw motorcycle rider
illegally driving up the center lane and
I thought why can't we use motorcyclists
to deliver milk in and out of New York
we collected from women that have an
excess amount of milk we process it test
it and distribute it to hospitals for
premature infants and to the community
at large Marla was born four months
early I brought Marlo home after 161
days in the NICU I stopped producing
breast milk and all of Marlo's doctors
required Marlo to continue on breast
milk because putting her on formula
would gravely endanger her life I had to
find a way to be able to give my
daughter breast milk and I found donor
milk since then we've been getting
deliveries from the milk bank we get
delivery once a month it's three hundred
and thirty bottles three ounces this
minor cycles is the sound of hope
[Music]
they're bringing life liquid life or a
small baby I don't know every time I
give Marlo a bottle I start to think
about what's in there it's not just one
woman's work I know the hard work energy
labor love dedication and sacrifice that
goes into every ounce we don't waste a
drop around here it's priceless
[Music]